Last night, I initiated
official lockdown procedure.
-(alarm blaring)
-That's right.
Shit has gotten real.
No one is allowed
in or out of the bunker,
besides my opponent tonight,
musician and visual artist
Kim Gordon.
-(cheering, applause)
-Yes.
She's promoting the film, Don't
Worry, He Won't Get Far on
Foot.
I hope she finds her way
through my trap maze.
Because... opposers,
we are in this together.
Together, we will fight back
against the forces
trying to shut down truth
and devour America!
But first...
-(alarm stops) -we got to sell
some great products.
It's the ShOpposition Fire Sale.
Look, if they have their way,
tomorrow is our last show,
so we're here to sell you some
products to help you navigate
the globo-fascist
news cycle without us.
And though I've never lied
to you yet this episode, and...
I'm not gonna start now.
This has nothing to do
with us needing money,
or my numerous gambling debts.
This is about helping you.
Just like my buddy, Alex Jones,
over at InfoWars.
He makes around seven
to 12 million dollars a year
selling diet supplements alone.
(chuckles)
More than enough to settle
-one of his many lawsuits.
-(laughter)
And we have ten times
the deals he does.
Let's take a look
at these incredible deals.
Laura Grey, what amazing
products do you have?
Oh, you're gonna
love this, Jordan.
We here at the ShOpposition
know the best way
to get ready for a fight
is to stay ready.
And nothing keeps you readier
than fear!
But what happens if you
aren't just naturally afraid
of nearly everything?
That's when you need...
ShOpposition brand Fear Goggles.
(laughter)
These goggles
are specially designed
to keep your anxiety high,
so you can see the truth.
Is that a professional athlete
kneeling to protest
police brutality?
Just slip on your goggles and...
Oh, my God!
It's blatant disrespect
for the flag
and a violent protest
against America!
(gasps):
Oh...
Hey. Is that two black men
calmly sitting in a Starbucks?
Fear Goggles on and...
Help! It's turbo ISIS
come to attack me
and steal
my half caf mocha frap!
KLEPPER:
Oh, I'll tell you.
Lookin' good, Laura.
And remember, opposers,
if you don't see a threat,
you're just not looking
hard enough.
Kobi Libii, what incredible
ShOpposition product
do you have for us?
-Jordan, you're gonna love this.
-Gentlemen, I'm sorry,
I'd like to report a criminal.
He is a man.
He is standing inside,
wearing...
Laura, take off the goggles!
Oh, hey, Kobi.
Uh, fun fact, opposers,
Laura's called 911 on me
at least 27 times.
Which is all the proof you need
that those goggles work.
You know what else works
like a cursed demon charm,
our ShOpposition brand
Slippery Slope 'N' Slide.
(takes deep breath)
You'll have hours
of fun in the sun
while learning to make
the best kind of argument,
the Slippery Slope kind.
At the top of the slide, we see
a peaceful immigrant family
entering the U.S.,
but soon your local Burger King
starts selling empanadas,
your child has a playdate
with someone named Julio,
and before you know it--
my God, what's that!
A group of vicious
MS-13 gang members! Watch out!
Those face tattoos might bite.
When you whiz down this baby,
you'll find yourself
sliding down a mental slope
into refreshing,
splash-tastic xenophobia.
It's almost July,
get yours now.
Also available in "gay marriage
leads to pet (bleep).”
Oh, no.
This is a must-have for summer.
And the sale price of just
$49.99 is lower than Mike Pence
when he lovingly ties the
president's shoes every morning.
Aaron and Josh,
looks like you've got
a really big deal over there.
Yes, Jordan,
we are a very big deal
because we make everything
a big deal
if it's something we care about.
Like, remember when
the Boy Scouts decided
to let girls in and libs were
all, like, "Woo-hoo,"
and we were all like,
"But it's the 'Boy' Scouts,"
and they were all like, "Is that
the hill you want to die on?”
And we were like, "Yes! Yes!
Watch us die..."
on our one-of-a-kind
Hill to Die On.
(cheering and applause)
No fight is too small to make
a huge (bleep) deal over.
Not enough people saying
"Merry Christmas"?
Die on that hill.
I have to think for two seconds
about your "preferred pronouns"?
-Die on that hill.
-KLEPPER: Oh.
Give that guy a TV Oscar.
Shopposers,
get your hands on your very own
Hill to Die On today.
Tucker Carlson,
I'm looking at you.
It's the perfect prop for what
you naturally do every night.
But our great products keep
flying off the shelves.
Tim Baltz, tell us how many
satisfied Shopposers we've got.
Dozens, Jordan,
dozens of thousands.
The Shopposition inbox is jammed
with glowing reviews,
like this one for our Cayenne
Heart-Accelerator pills.
Dr. Richard Jenkins writes,
"This product is fatal
at any dosage." One star.
That's one star,
the best kind of star.
Okay, everyone, I'm sure
what he really means
is "fatally great
at keeping you alert."
Tomato/potato, Jordan.
The point is, that last product
will kill you.
Let's move on to another
satisfied customer.
This review is for our
Shopposition-brand
Bone Condenser.
Rupert19-- 19-- Rupert19--
Boy.
(laughter)
-Rupert1955.
-Rupert1955 writes:
"Pill size is way too big.
Don't know how this is supposed
to fit up there." One star.
-Nice. -I think that's enough
product reviews for now.
Shopposers, this is serious.
We're under attack, and with our
show going off the air,
you need these products
so you can fight the globalists
on your own.
There's nothing strange about a
media outlet making you afraid,
then selling you products
to profit off that fear.
Alex Jones tells you tap water
is feminizing men,
then goes ahead and sells you
male vitality supplements.
If that seems awfully convenient
to you,
maybe you're just not seeing
things clearly.
In fact, you know what?
Let me bring out
my trusty gaslight.
There.
Look at that gaslight.
If you think
I'm making up problems
and then selling you
the solution,
your brain's just broken.
Good thing I sell
brain-fixer pills,
now on sale at
theshopposition.com.
Is this gaslight getting bigger?
Buy my drugs.
Get on board.
Who doesn't like pills?
Yummy, yummy in my tummy.
Pills make daddy go vroom-vroom.
Don't question it.
You need them.
We're at war.
How do you know?
I already told you.
Look at the gaslight.
(bleep) it.
Buy the gaslight...
with five reasonable payments
of $29.66666.
Wow, that is a deal!
(cheers and applause)
Our phone lines are open,
Opposers,
and we need you
to win this fight.
The fight continues.